Ukraine and its Western allies have hit
back at Russian claims that Kiev is
planning to detonate a radioactive bomb
on its own territory president velodimir
zielinski fears Moscow could be using
the allegation as a pretext to escalate
the conflict earlier Russia's defense
minister Sergey shoigu called Britain
France and turkey to tell them of the
kremlin's concerns that the situation on
the ground was rapidly deteriorating
and we are joined Now by Pavel podvik he
is senior researcher of weapons of mass
destruction at the United Nations thank
you so much for joining us how high is
your concern that such a weapon like
this could be used in this conflict
well I frankly uh I don't think that
this is very uh very plausible because
uh the uh what is uh known as dirty bomb
but he's really uh not a useful in any
sense uh military or political or any
other
oh if if
it how could it affect the situation on
the battlefield and for civilians
especially given that there are claims
and counter claims that it is indeed
poised to be used
no look uh the uh the journey bomb is
basically an explosive device that is
supposed to disperse certain amount of
red activity but the the reality is that
it it is a very inefficient way of of
doing so and in fact uh if the the most
it could do it could contaminate an area
of an order of I know tens or maybe
uh hundreds of meters
so uh it is really impossible to imagine
that this uh this kind of thing would
have any effect on anything other than
uh on those people who would uh happen
to be in the in this kind of a 10 meter
uh radius from the explosion the
ukrainians for their part they say that
the Russians um are are making claims um
and and might use such claims as a
pretext
um to escalate the war
um if
such a dirty bomb were to be used for
example on the Russian side what sort of
reaction do you think
um there would be from Ukraine's Western
partners
well it it's again I think people just
need to to be calm and to understand
what this dirty bomb is and what it
isn't and again I just do not see how
this event even if it happens could
really change anything in in this
conflict or any uh any political
opposition as if you will
of public joining us from Geneva thank
you so much
thank you
in other developments on the ground
Russia is continuing to attack Southern
Ukraine with missiles and drones in the
north fears are growing that Moscow
could be planning a joint Invasion with
Belarusian troops now Russia recently
deployed thousands of soldiers there
fueling fears that they could be about
to open up a second front
as CW's funny for Char reports from the
charnev region nearby Villages are
preparing for the worst
fear keeps you alert when it's dangerous
the soldier says mortar attacks and
shelling have increased here and paper
maps work when technology doesn't
he's taking us close to the water with
Belarus
there's no need to spend time thinking
will an offensive happen or not we are
preparing for the enemy to come
this part of Northern Ukraine is where
Russian forces swept through when they
first headed for Kiev at the start of
the war
the push back work though ukrainians
retook the area in April
we Patrol these positions this forest
and we're really proud to have such
trophies for the Ukrainian Army
so this is a former Russian position
yes it is
this is what's left of one Russian
Fighting Vehicle after those battles in
March the soldiers here expect new ones
to arrive soon
we are prepared motivated we have no way
back we are defending our homeland
many here suspect that their neighbors
in Belarus had helped the Russians from
the start but now it's official on the
other side of the frontier they are
joining forces they say they are
preparing to defend themselves but
people here at the border with Belarus
are sure that would take the form of an
attack although they don't know when it
will come
villagers know they are Russian soldiers
just 30 kilometers away
tell me who should I go to who I'm not
afraid of the winter but I am afraid of
the Russians
they are traumatized by the violence and
very worried that Russian forces might
return but they won't leave
this is our homeland we were born here
we live here we won't go anywhere
Valentina like most people in this
Village has lived here all her life she
desperately wants peace
that's what the soldiers in the forest
say they are fighting for
I want this war to stop with me I have
much to lose there's only one life but
it's better I fight this than my
children or my grandchildren and yet
some of his children's generation have
not been spared the war they're prepared
for the winter for the Russians and now
for the belarusians using fear to stay
alert
and let's bring in funny fatr who joins
us now from Keith funny how are
ukrainians reacting to these allegations
about the possible use of a dirty bomb
if you listen to Mr Clipper the foreign
minister here from the very official
Ukrainian perspective they call it quote
absurd these accusations made by Russia
there in fact they are saying that this
is being used as a information a
misinformation campaign by Russia to
Stage a false flag operation which
basically means that then Russia is
going to accuse Ukraine of planting this
bomb and accusing Ukraine for for doing
this so now Ukraine is accusing Russia
that they're actually going to plant
this bomb however if you look back on
the context here and Vladimir Putin who
has said recently that if Ukraine
attacks Russia and so on and they do
consider an ex territory in Ukraine such
as Hairston Zappa regia region the
donbas region as Russia right now if
Ukraine attacks it then Russia is going
to resort to nuclear bombs and what I
find quite particularly interesting here
is how ordinary citizens have reacted to
this development you will really find
reactions from a scale of very angry to
very concerned people who are angry
because they say quote they feel
terrorized by this ongoing fear and
fear-mongering by Russia but you will
also find people just simply say so much
so many things have happened over the
course of the past eight months here in
Ukraine that they believe anything and
everything that's quote inhumane is
possible and that it is possible that
Russia may actually plant or have such a
plan and actually execute this plan and
have a dirty bomb in place for
ukrainians and for Ukrainian civilians
to suffer if you do not know Sarah what
is going to happen but one thing is
clear that not just rhetorically but in
many ways if you look at what happened
during the past of just two weeks things
are escalating here in Ukraine and that
comes amid funny reports of a Russian
troop build up in Belarus you you've
been to the Border what are people there
telling you
I was stunned when I spoke to a locals
in a village there very close to the
Belarusian border just about 25 to 30
kilometers away they said they're much
more afraid of Vladimir Putin and the
Russian forces than of winter arriving
and you have to see that so much of
critical infrastructure of energy
infrastructure has been damaged or
destroyed over the past few weeks
elderly women who really are concerned
about the winter but they say they're
rather more concerned about Vladimir
Putin does send a message to you just
how much you're traumatized over the
fact that Russian forces have been
through that village already where we
were in the northern part of Ukraine at
the first phase at the beginning of this
full-scale escalation this full scale
Invasion uh in in March and April and
soldiers themselves have a very own
perspective as well as they're preparing
for that offensive likely to come from
Belarus how about on the active front in
the South near her son
well Ukrainian forces definitely
continue with their counter-offensive in
Harrison region their goal is certainly
to liberate Harrison City while on the
uh on the Russian or from the Russian
side the Russian forces actually have
withdrawn from certain settlements there
in Houston region and are also calling
on civilians as they say for to save and
protect their lives and to leave a part
of the West Bank of the deeper River
where Hassan city is located and go and
move towards a Crimea or to Russian
occupied territories what of course a
lot of civilians there I see as a force
bill of being forcefully moved to to
other parts of of the country whereas
many of course also would like to go to
a Ukrainian control territories I expect
a lot of more chaos actually in that
region in Harrison region as Ukrainian
forces want to make Headway there but of
course Russians even though from some
settlements they have withdrawn they're
not just gonna give up on her sincerity
is very strategically important to them
so what is to come that's the question
which actually takes us back to the
first question what is going to be the
reaction of Russia if Ukraine succeeds
to liberate such a strategic Town
Harrison City nobody knows funny for
Char and Keith thank you